a lot more people need to use social
media lives the way streamers use twitch
like everybody doesn't go live cuz they
think they have to do something I think
you should go live while you're eating
lunch attention is the number one asset
vayer Nation what is good it is time
again for podcast with friends where I
bring people from different worlds doing
cool [__] and we just kind of chop it up
I'm excited about this episode we're
going to talk about a bunch of different
themes but first like the last episode
which I thought really hit I want to
make sure that our friends here get a
little bit of time to let all of you
know who they are what they're up to
what their journey is about so we're
going to start with ladies first here
why don't you tell the vayer nation who
you are and what you do hello vayer
Nation my name is di Kim um I have the
weirdest maybe not the weirdest job now
but I have a very weird job my Shiva Ena
went viral 10 years ago so I dressed him
up in menswar I have a history in
fashion I used to design for Ralph
Lauren but then I quit my dream job cuz
I wanted to spend time with my dog so
here I am I'm still at it and I've had
the most incredible time and been able
to meet the most incredible people so
I'm happy to be here today thank you
tell them about the brand that you make
that I rock with very heavily so it the
brand is called Men's Wear dog and um
you know we dress up my shea you know
and we actually adopted a Jindo as well
so he's learning the chops of how to
style and wear clothing um but I put
men's wear in um on dogs and basically
it's like a fresh new way of looking at
Fashion like traditionally I feel like
sometimes you look at these like models
with like sixpack and you're a little
bit intimidated by the ad but when a dog
is wearing Men's Wear first of all it's
a dog so you're like yes cool appeals to
all demographics and also like on
another level you see The Styling
because it's no longer a human being so
you're able to see the products yes so
in that way we've been able to sort of
showcase men's wear like lifestyle items
in different sort of like fun
interesting ways I love that and the
best part is like I love spending time
with my dogs so every post is like a
memory of like oh I remember that day
when bod went somewhere and he peed on
this person's carpet and I had to
apologize but then we had so much fun
later so that's sort of like the joy
that I get from it and I wouldn't have
it any other way yeah I think you're
just such a great example of like what
my belief is is that people are scared
to make leaps and do different [__]
because nobody's ever done it or they're
worried about judgment but the only way
to like actually create meaningful [__]
and most of all deep Joy is to do it
your
way right and so absolutely you know
like I'm sure like if I read what's
going on just all the people listening
on the podcast remember we are always
live with podcasts with friends on
Twitch go to Gary
ve.com twitch big shout out to everyone
in there when I look at mix one two
three go to go and John Carney and all
the people in here Katy teacher like you
know when they hear like wait a minute
is she saying that she's got like dude
wear but she puts it on a dog first like
like that's just different and like many
people think it's silly and many people
think it's super dope but for me what's
most interesting is you love it yeah
like and like that's actually I believe
the fuel that gives anyone the chance to
actually pull it off I feel like there's
two ways to pull [__] off fuel that is
based on like joy and gratitude and you
[__] just you're in your [__] and the
other one is like dark [__] like Star
Wars like Darth Vader like Envy jealousy
anger you got to prove something to the
world you're going to show your mom that
you're not a piece of [__] real [__]
like you're going to like real [__] like
like all the stuff that I think and you
can get there the problem is the people
that get there through the dark side
can't sustain
it right so like everyone's trying to
make it the problem is most people
people don't realize once you make it
you also want to sustain it because if
you make it the dark way Envy jealousy
anger chips on like you're it's going to
get real dark you keep it that way too
yeah cuz once you get Fame and money
Andor Fame Andor money and you got up
the game in the dark way [__] gets
really dark I don't know if you would
consider this the dark uh side of it but
like I had no savings or and no backup
plans and I actually don't have family
um in New York so if this didn't work
out then I'd be like I'd really be in
trouble just for I have to I I think the
dark side is the reason you want to be
successful is you got scorned by someone
in 11th grade and like you're your fuel
is I'm going to show Sally instead of
this is my passion yeah you're the dark
side is like you you have jealous DNA
and parents that taught you jealousy and
you're just coming up the game and the
reason you want to be successful is
you're you're mad at everybody else
being successful and just not a good
energy of why you want to grow you're
not driven by gratitude or Joy right no
I think I think external factors I think
exactly it's external versus internal
and like I you know I think no no I
don't think yours is the dark side I
think here's what would have happened
quote unquote if it didn't work out you
would have gotten a job that's true
that's true like no I'm proud of you and
like I want more people to go do that
because I think most people don't jump
because they're scared of what people
think about their jump yeah yeah like
most people should jump especially in
their youth because if it doesn't work
out you can just go back to the thing
that you're not enjoying right now that
is making you want to jump my man for
sure what's up everybody my name is OED
Padilla I'm from Oceanside California um
I'm an artist producer
musician singer songwriter a little bit
of everything but yeah amazing thank you
tell us more build on that how' you come
up what what what what what's been your
most like successful thing at this point
from your perspective or maybe from the
Market's perspective where you at me and
my boys have been doing these uh like
cinematic one minute videos and they've
been going viral yeah um that's been
what's going on but that's been how did
that down how did that happen we just
had this idea this Summer that we were
like hey let's just do these short
videos we're do one week after another
keep posting them and came up with these
Concepts and then they took off what was
the first concept um the first one was
me um outside of my car kind of working
on it and then all of a sudden I come
out and start rapping and then go back
to fixing the car and basically it was
like this take on hipop a lot of it is
like Rah flashy and I wanted to kind of
showcase Blue Collar yep you know in
like my everyday life of like what I see
you know and did that one hit or did
that one H right off the top right off
the top so you guys had this thesis real
life not the music playing Boom you go
into it boom you go back to it and it
just worked yeah did anything Inspire
that that you all like elements that you
saw in other [__] just our surroundings
like where I'm from and you know my pops
is a he was he's a pastor but also he
was a gardener so I used to go work with
him every morning and so just seeing
that
and all of our parents all of our the
jobs like especially Latinos you know of
course that's what we see and so I
wanted toing came like like I was born
in a different country and like it was
Merchant life right just like people own
Bas my dad own a liquor store and like
at 14 I worked every [__] Saturday
stocking shelves for 10 hours a day work
ethic is ingrained in immigrant mindset
yeah yeah it's our biggest Advantage
it's our big our big our not every I I
know unlimited lazy immigrants and I
know unlimited people that aren't
immigrants that work hard but the
advantage of immigrant life is you see
up close and personal that work ethic is
the variable for sure complaining is the
weapon of choice of many immigrants tend
not to usually cuz wherever they came
from is not as good as here real talk
definitely not everything is perfect
here but there's a reason people [__]
come here absolutely my
man hey my name is Alan King I run a
fashion brand called a Kings the easiest
way to describe us now is we make you
feel like a king so I I push uh I push
conf yeah yeah I push I push a lot of
confidence and and uh growth through the
brand and um think about I I think about
uh where when we first came from and I
also got fairly Lucky in terms of one of
my first products went viral uh we had a
curv gene that friend of a friend posted
on Reddit and uh you know that was my
first introduction to social media
seeing the community of slra denim just
kind of coming and finding my website
and getting early pre-order traction
from that so you had a pre- order a
product out someone posted it in a
proper denim Reddit Channel and all of a
sudden you just like wake up and shit's
just like pinging off in your [__]
Shopify yeah well this this
isif Shopify so however you get no I was
using Shopify what is that yeah by the
way I know I I launched an e-commerce
site in 1997 where the server was in my
dad's liquor storees closet and when the
power would go out cuz of a rainstorm in
the neighborhood the website would go
down like it wild it was I mean in 1997
back to early e-commerce War Stories We
still didn't have our shopping cart
proper so I probably took 10 phone calls
a day in 1999 walking people through how
to get through the shopping cart like
[__] that you kids take for granted
people like yo I'm stuck I'm like you
got to put the credit card in they're
like literally like real talk like OG
War Stories of e-commerce and then
people like well I don't trust it like
people don't get it like all the web
stuff right now with metam they're like
I'm like this is how web one was people
were scared to put the credit card in
okay so you had that did you know the
post was coming or did you just wake up
to action on the pre-orders I I just
woke up to the traffic you got you saw
the emails how did you I'm actually
genuinely curious how you first smelled
some shit's popping off emails yeah it
was it was the email orders and then I
saw the traffic and I was oh where's the
truly the like phone you look and you
hit like you open your email thing and
there's like 67 messages you're like
what the [__] and you see they're all
order
it wasn't uh like 67 messages right away
but it was just I'm on my email and you
know I wasn't getting much orders at the
time you were working your emails
opening it's like Bing like oh yeah
awesome got one and Bing yeah and
probably by the third Bing you're like
yo something's happening right yeah yeah
like serotonin's happening yeah because
before then there was no uh it was just
all friends that knew I was posting
there there's really nothing like and
you just went through it with the video
there's really nothing like the moment
where you're feeling something for the
first time that it's happening
especially when you've been building
yeah sure yeah that moment it's
like what was your moment um so I
actually just took a picture of my dog
as a joke as like cuz I was bored and I
had samples what you do and it's what I
do cuz I'm a weirdo and then I posted on
my Facebook my friends were like you
need to just like put this on Tumblr
Tumblr was like those days Instagram I
was an early investor in Tumblr yes yes
um and so you know just posted thinking
nothing and then the next day we had
like thousands of notifications it was
like and then the day after we got
invited to go to like Anderson Cooper or
something it happened within like two
days and I was like this is really fast
like this happens really quickly so yeah
I remember just how how did the brand
start where did you grow up uh so I was
born in Chinatown low E side and uh the
brand started for me because I fell in
love with fashion through most mostly
reselling so the the rise yeah flipping
like buying and selling sneakers like
Supremes and Jordans got it um you
started that when I started this when it
was like uh 14 13 14 damn staying in L
like how old are you uh I was I'm 26 now
so you caught the tail end of standing
in line or you did it all online uh I I
was mostly I didn't really believe in
standing in line I I caught the Facebook
group so this is after the forums i c
the Facebook group communities and then
uh I I basically this is pre-stock egg
so you can find pricing yeah there was
arbs there was tons ofs so I would see
the sneaker is like 220 the guy is
willing to sell it but it's actually
going for 300 and I would buy it from
him and then sell it and just meet
somebody up like 10 minutes away yeah
and that was the game yeah and then at
what point were you like one day I want
to do my own brand yeah I I actually it
was a very clear uh moment I was I was
uh I think it was 15 years old and I
walked by BAP and Y3 yeah and I just saw
the alling the energy and the lines and
I was like wow this is this is so
different than anything else I've seen
in fashion and boy you remember when you
met AJ my boy and AJ my brother AJ met
freshman year of college in 19 in 2009
oh 2005 2005 and the biggest the
funniest thing I think about their
freshman year is how much Bape AJ wore
constantly obsessed he was obsessed um
so the energy and you were like [__] I
want this yeah I I I think it started as
a very simple idea actually it was just
oh I want to build something I felt like
there was something missing too um there
skinny jeans wasn't uh necessarily a
huge thing I was extremely skinny and uh
I had to tailor my jeans and uh I was
like oh there's something missing maybe
in the market that I can create and um I
I just started with basic like screen
printing t-shirts and uh I tried to make
like a I had another product that went
semi viral was like a ninja hoodie uh
where I put like a scarf in a hoodie and
then um I just thought that I just kept
creating and then uh I knew that one day
I wanted to create a brand but uh the
first product that kind of caught
traction um just randomly was this curve
pant that was called like a j-shaped
pant and just went yeah that started it
yeah what are you thinking about most
these days I'm going to get these V
friends packs out we're going to play a
game in a minute but let's go back
around the horn what are you thinking
about most these days like if I was like
yo like real talk like if we were best
friends since we were three and we
caught up for dinner because we're both
busy and we've had 100 days since we
really chopped it up obviously we've
been texting and I was like yo what's
most going on like what are you most
contemplating what's either most
exciting what's what are you most
concerned about what are you trying to
figure out what's most on your mind
right
now I feel like this year for me has
been a year of connection reconnection
and kind of like internal
contemplation um we are living in a
really fast society and we live in New
York City which is even faster and I
think in the churn and the grind it's
easy to sort of lose track of what the
goal is where you're headed you know so
this year I tried to be really
intentional and spend lots of time with
family and friends um and the balance is
really what I'm striking the balance of
health of work of people of being there
for myself spiritually um so yeah just
kind of trying to find the middle I I
don't want to say optimize cuz that
sounds really marketing for my own life
but that's been on my mind lately right
you're trying to find the middle right
because you have ambition you're trying
to build but you don't want to be in a
place where like you just wake up a
morning and be like what the [__] did I
do this for feel soulless absolutely and
success to me I think is like everyone
has their own version of success and I'm
trying to really fine-tune what that is
for me um and really everyone I think
could benefit from figuring out you know
is My Success really money is it really
fame or is it whatever it's never money
cuz it really depends on your background
it's money at first especially if you
didn't come from it you're completely
seduced by thinking cuz it's always
happiness yeah but you but you think
money unlocks the happiness cuz you grew
up in a household where money stress
made everything [__] up this is why I
always say the kid that is born in a
household with no money but is happy and
their parents are happy all day in those
first five 6 3 years she and he is the
gangster of the world cuz they were
taught from the get that money is not
the anecdote yeah that's me I'm aware
why I'm a happy person I was I was
raised by a mother that was pure
sunshine and happiness and everything is
good regardless gratitude don't want
[__] never put material [__] on a
pedestal never talk [__] about any
anyone never any beat anyone it was just
all [__] love love love and we didn't
have [__] lived in Queens in a studio
apartment like this office with six
seven eight family members depending on
how everyone was coming over from Russia
at the time and I thought we had it
great I didn't have [__] like by 10 I
was like on my own meaning my parents
would maybe buy me like a Hanukkah
present but like and a birthday present
but kids like I didn't even know kids
got things not on their birthday or a
big
holiday and so I became Unstoppable
that's what I wish on people but to your
point like like what are you aiming for
like you know people think it's money
and I understand every time I say money
doesn't buy you happiness I get
bombarded big shout out to all the
first-time Chatters Stephen 66
789 Zer saying hi Gary as a first time
chatter on Twitch all the people in
there as we're talking right now I'm
focusing on y'all but I know one or two
or three people been like [__] that I'll
take the money I get it I get it I grew
up in neighbor my whole life I grew up
in lower middle class neighborhoods my
whole life so I know how people see it I
just also am 48 [__] years old and
have really lived it and I've lived
around nothing I've lived around nothing
but poverty and wealth my whole life at
this point now that I've lived my 48 and
it's just Crystal [__] clear I don't
envy or excuse me I don't judge I have
no judgment on anyone who's like [__]
you Gary I'm going for that paper I need
a [__] Lambo go do you but just talk
to me when you do can't wait to chop it
up 5 years after you got paper yeah
let's talk about it then yeah and so you
know what are you doing it for to tr I
think what all of us need to do it for
is to wake up every single morning and
feel decent not every day is going to be
awesome by the way full transparency
yesterday was one of my weird 10 I get
10 weird days a year Real Talk where I
wake up and I'm like oh this is what it
feels like I don't even know what it was
maybe the jet season was over I got some
stresses at work
I'm a human I've got I got life and it
was just like kind of like I had to
grind through yesterday a little bit
more like like literally 345 days a year
I'm coasting perspective Happy
Everything can go wrong I'm like I'm
good as long as like the five or seven
people I love the most in the world are
healthy [__] all this [__] yesterday
kind of just like it was yesterday was
rainy right weather [__] me it was
raining in the morning right like a yeah
it was like like I don't know like just
and so like I you know even it's so
ironic we're talking about this the fact
that I got to taste it a little bit
yesterday for a couple hours I was good
by midday I kind of got out of it I was
like okay like this is what I don't want
for people plus I lived in my whole
childhood I'm looking at my report card
up there like every Monday wait where
I'm definely look at it after my man
take that down big man take it down I
want them to see it this was 12 years of
my life and really was about eight or
nine that's my report
card is your teach name on it you can
get stuck in that momentum of being in
that head space how did I not no I said
you can get I think that's a lot of
people's you know that's 90% of the
world 90% of the world has decided it's
bad the reason I was able to get out
yesterday how crazy is that you've
gotten A's consistently in fizzed
congratulations that's right I'm a I'm
called a Gym Class Hero I got five A's
in my life in high school four in gym
and one in health senior year I got a D
in health once um I
I think most of the world does that my
man all I all I want the the reason
we're the four of us are sitting here is
all I want to do is put deposits down
every day to try to help the there's 458
people on Twitch right now in a year
after we keep doing this there'll be
4,000 and whether it's 458 4,000 one all
I want I'm just looking right now right
whether it's pink hair mutant right
whether it's Petra
G55 whether it's high Anthony 417 if one
[__] person in the hour that we all
allocated to this hears one thing from
one of the four of us that allows them
to stop it yeah everyone's in it my man
because the world is really good at
scaring you for sure it's the
politician's fault it's your parents
fault it's the government's fault it's
this famous people's fault it's the
algorithm's fault it's your boss's fault
all it tells you is it's everyone's
fault when meanwhile you were in full
control of your happiness
you don't like the president move to
Sweden real talk like you were actually
in control I was born in the Soviet
Union the Soviet Union is like North
Korea people in North Korea right now
can't
leave can not leave a country that is a
jail I was born in one of those places
from 1917 to 1991 people could not leave
except for a few political things the
way I got out was there was a big event
and Israel and Spain and America got
together and made a deal with Russia cuz
it was starting to get poor nobody knew
it yet cuz they spent all their money on
[__] bombs instead of [__] food
and they [__] up but like my
grandmother didn't get to like my great
grandparents got to America when they
were 70 they lived in jail their whole
life country that was jail like people
just don't have gratitude my mom lost
Serv mom at five my dad lost his dad to
15 like I just don't know like there's
just unlimited [__] hardships and
people are complaining about dumb [__]
I'm not a
millionaire like how do I get out of it
and how am I trying to get people out of
it by talking about perspective and
gratitude everyone's spending all their
time what on what they don't
have meanwhile you have I'm on the board
of Charity water a nonprofit that gets
water in Africa to places that don't
have access to clean water we had the
Galla last week There's 753 million
people on earth almost 10% of the Earth
that do not have access to clean
water the women like little girls don't
go to school because at 12: they start
walking 10 miles with a bucket on their
head to go to a place to get clean water
and walk back and it takes the entire
day the [__] are people talking about
that are on [__]
twitch or who have a [__] cell phone
if you have a $1,000 computer in your
[__] hands shut your [__] mouth we
need more gratitude we're [__]
spoiled out
here yeah and you know what always
happens right you complain about all
this dumb [__] until some real [__] goes
down and then you change your tune God
forbid someone in your family is
terminally ill or suddenly dies all of a
sudden you're not worried about that you
didn't sell a million hoodies or that
you didn't or that somebody you're
competing with got the cosign from Drake
and you didn't all of a sudden you
change your tune when your grandma's
dead for sure yeah and so I don't want
people to have terrible life events to
get their perspective right I'd rather
us get our perspective right in
conversations like this thoughts on
that I also feel like adversity is kind
of if if I was to you know have a kid
and say I want this kid to be the
greatest person on Earth I wouldn't give
them an easy life of course I would want
them to have different challenges and
the bigger challenges will make them
more um resilient I think it'll make
them more inventive but it gets hard
because your parents love you like I
have children you want it to be good for
you love them more than breathing yeah
it's really easy to talk about I'm going
to make it tougher on my kid until you
have one yeah and then you love that
[__] more than you love anything in the
world and you're like you almost can't
help you you you could see it happening
but you can't look at the you're talking
about you're talking about resilience
for a kid your dog is bougie as
[__] actually my dog's the worst example
because he hasn't done anything for
himself in his whole life but I feel
like he's a dog so I can treat him that
way but do you know what I mean like
real talk your dog is like insecure as
[__] and it's tummy but you don't know
it cuz they can't
talk why actually super cocky like
you'll see when he comes over but but
fake Cockiness if he had it too light he
you know he's a dog in New York wearing
expensive clothes I promise you if he
went to nework right now and found a dog
outside that dog would [__] your dog up
absolutely like a kid like get him
thoughts on this I think that I just
think about my folks so my mom came here
from Mexico my dad came here from Costa
Rica and like I think about them at my
age like I can't imagine being in a
completely different country and that
perspective to where I'm like I really
can't complain about anything either you
know do you complain yeah of course
about what normally like right now how
old are you 29 where at this point in
your life if you're you know if we're
being vulnerable and trying to bring
value to the audience what where do you
feel like your head goes to yourself
what do what do you feel like you
complain
about I think other people yeah good I
love you for that meaning meaning other
people's success that you want or other
people's actions towards you I think
actions and then
also I look at certain people and I'm
like duh like talk it through I want
more I want them to I know where you're
going but I want them to hear this talk
it through it's how the talk it you you
see other people and the things that
they complain about and the things that
uh are so important to them but then
they don't even understand what's going
on in their head but it's such a big
issue and and what do you do about
that cuz this is the part that I'm most
interested in in a world where I think
most people see people doing dumb [__]
and they go duh I'm trying to figure out
how to get cool people like you to
deploy compassion and empathy and and
try to help them like I think we've lost
our neighbor civility thing for sure I
think we're all in our
[__] I think you're right I I just walk
because I think everything should be
pure simple everything's duh to me yeah
like I I can't deal with people not
being nice all I see is people not being
nice around dumb [__] this Starbucks
literally there's Starbucks underneath
my house I saw somebody reaming out the
Starbucks person the other there's 900
[__] people in the store we're in
[__] huts and yards
like give the kid a [__] minute like
your life is that bad that you want to
[__] on a [__] person pouring you the
wrong milk and the coffee I bring it up
all the time because it always triggers
me people literally yelling that they
didn't get the almond milk and they gave
them oat milk right like real [__] do
you feel like that's projection of it's
everything's projection yeah this is why
I'm going with him on this of like if
you we're lucky and we got good
perspective because your mom and dad all
that I I think we got to stop judging
people
that and I also but I also because if
you make it make it make it like the way
I want you to your kid no matter how
hard you try you can't fake environment
for sure and so your kid's going to be
duh yeah truly that's what happens with
like the Immigrant parents come over
build a little Foundation number two
comes in [__] builds it and number
three gets the payoff but it's the fake
payoff to your point cuz they're the
most insecure of the bunch your parents
are the strongest of the bunch cuz they
lived in some [__] and were just like
grateful for what they [__] had you
got Americanized and see all especially
in the rap game and you you know you're
a kid you're 29 like you're coming up
you're seeing things you got Ambitions
it's starting to happen right now but
like my big thing is like I don't want
to be duh towards people I want to like
put my hand on her shoulder and be like
yo be grateful I just want I want to
make kindness and gratitude and all this
like warm [__]
cool I think that's far
my other point that I was going to say
was if if I can't do that then just me
being like Oh I'm not going to act that
way love that like being that for
somebody else you know like yo you may
act that way but I'm not I'm I'm cool
that you know love I love that and I by
the way real talk I get the that's the
only thing that goes through my head duh
but it's pure projection the best thing
that's gone for me is anytime I see hate
towards me or anybody house I go deep
into compassion straight
compassion I'm like that person's hurt
yeah and we don't have that gear right
now for sure we're in full fight you see
something you don't like you fight them
back you everyone's trying to convince
everyone to see the world the way they
this is why politics is all [__] up as
if your world view is how every other
person should see it we all have
different experiences let's open these
cards while you answer this I want to oh
here's this card so this is the be
friend's card game on podast guess with
friends you're going to look at the
cards and I want to know which character
and then we'll go to you which character
you most resonate that you
pulled damn I got a good pack I feel
like I feel like three three of them
three of them for me really pop I'm
going to have to debate this I'll talk
mine out while you guys think I got
hardworking wombat which I really [__]
with because I think hard work is the
[__] variable I got decisive duck
which is not only cute as [__] look at
the eyes decisive duck is not only cute
as [__] uhhuh but I really do think
decisiveness is a superpower I think
people wallow too much and then maybe my
favorite character of them all ambitious
Angel ambition is [__] real that you
got ambitious Angel Ambi Angel is a
beast she's a gangster in this world of
this is my Pokemon meets Marvel meets
Sesame Street world all right ladies
guess what I got as my first card a dog
let's go poised pug I got poised pug
which is very appr apprpriate because
dogs I got skilled skeleton mhm I've got
focused Falcon which I'm working on this
year focusing better well-rounded wart
hog which also kind of alludes to the
conversation about balance you got to
pick one this is really [__]
yeah no political correctness you got to
pick one I'm by the way I'm going to go
with I'm going to go with hardworking
wad I just I think we're demonizing hard
work a little bit too much that's not
again like I don't believe in Burnout I
don't believe in any of that [__] that's
crazy but too many people think you can
build something without hard work all of
a sudden and that's [__] up I picked
well-rounded warthog I love that yeah
trying to be more well-rounded yeah I
love cuz I want to be happy hell [__]
yes my man I got ambitious Angel yep
meticulous Magpie yep wild wabby and
Keen King Fisher and I'm going with king
fisher you like the king fisher yeah
yeah I love that little down under bird
I love that all right I have a enamored
emu yep gifted golfer legit llama and
windso wolf and I am going to go with
the wolf you like the way it looks I
like the way it looks the tail is
fire I I Dre so I drew all these
characters oh okay so they all started
off looking like that I drew all of them
and then we converted them into this
thing so back to the conversation we're
having at hand what do you think about
the last 5 10 minutes of this podcast
like what pops up in your head about
what you see you grew up in you know
your culture you know in in a in the
flip game like I know that world super
well cuz I grew up in in a different era
and obviously I know a lot of the kids
consume my content in that ecosystem New
York City Vibes down there like what's
your take on everything you just heard
yeah yeah I think that uh for me I grew
up with hard work instilled in me I
think coming from your parents as well
uh and also just doing things like it
was just a very common thing for me to
just do things that I didn't like to do
like it was completely just like hey
like you have to do these things you
know so let's say if I notice notice how
they're like yeah I I want to let you
keep going cuz I don't want to interrupt
you because I get excited and do that
but [__] that I love you for what you're
saying keep building on that like doing
[__] you don't want to was like not even
something we four thought was debatable
and now everyone thinks is in play yeah
yeah yeah yeah now now it feels
like a lot of 13-year-olds think they
have
choices we didn't think that way yeah so
I think that you know growing up with
that idea like knowing that hey like I
have to do these things and uh you know
life may not necessarily be easy at the
moment but uh you know things will they
like life isn't necessarily meant to be
easy and uh there like challenges the
way I think about it as I build uh the
brand and everything else I'm doing is
that you know if if life was easy
everybody would be able to get to where
I am or where I want to be but there's
you know there's uh do you think there's
an underlining delusion out there um
like that you could just wish your way
to like or do you feel like it's
entitlement do you think it's here's a
good question the the thing that we're
all touching on do you think it's
delusion or do you think it's
entitlement do you think people think
they can get to where they want to get
to without putting it in or do you think
that they've grown up in an environment
and in a culture where they think they
deserve it without doing the work I I
think it's just that we we see the
reward just right in front of us all the
time without everything behind it right
like if you look at real quick but real
quick I apologize to inter up because
it's a big argument everyone says oh
social media we just see I'm like yo I
grew up on MTV Cribs like it wasn't like
it wasn't like television Lifestyles of
the Rich and Famous was the biggest TV
show when I was a kid it's you know this
this narrative that everybody wants want
to play now they're like oh we're all
[__] up on this because we just see
chains and bottles and models and wealth
and yeah I'm like so did
we like so did we
period but you didn't feel like you
didn't feel like you uh you were
entitled to it in a sense we just first
of all we didn't think we there was no
idea that you could without a long time
like what changed was Mark Zuckerberg
became a billionaire at 25 the internet
changed everything and kids started to
believe that they could get it fast
right like we knew like when I was
coming up I was that guy at 14 I'm like
like everyone in my school knew like
this dude might actually win cuz he just
talks about it like he might I was
talking about buying the New York Jets
then like I'm a businessman and when it
was nerdy like on some nerdy [__] I was
selling baseball cards at lunch and
people were making fun of me like my
friends are like yo bro like girls like
you like why are you doing this that was
like a real conversation for me like my
friends were like some girls like you
but you're [__] it up and they were
like you're [__] it up for us I'm
like [__] you sit on your own feet I'll
sell them baseball cards you're like
you're going to be a nerd I'm like I do
not give a [__] but I thought then and I
was that kid I'm painting you that
picture that story for that I was like
okay when I'm 60 I'm gonna I'm gonna
when I'm 60 now people are like yo I'm
going to start a [__] Tik Tok and if
I don't pop in the first month like what
the [__] just happened so I don't think
we even knew that you could that's the
difference but people are taking the 1%
of 1% of 1% of 1% of 1% and deploying it
on themselves and not even understanding
what would make them happy most people
will tell you that got there the most
fun was getting there
yeah
yeah the thing that I'm most worried
about is kids are believing the [__]
this thing that I see from a lot of kids
saying like this whole generational
Warfare thing is [__] up us gen Z kids
are going to be the first generation
that doesn't make more money or more
success than our parents first of all I
know unlimited kids I grew up with and
we're Gen X that are not more successful
than their
parents like it you know we make these
blanket statements and it and people
believe
them like you got kids walking around
that are being told that they can't be
successful who've just decided they
can't and so they're depressed about it
and I'm like that generalizations have
nothing to do with
you nothing yeah I agree with that
please I agree with that and I also
think so many different Generations have
different things to offer and when
things are generalized too much it's
almost like you negate all the special
things that
um the input that you could have from
them and you just kind of block it like
you might think a certain generation is
cringe so you won't take their advice
but you don't understand that they have
like decades on you by the way by the
way as if the world has hasn't done a
bad enough job separating us on gender
and race and religion yeah now now we're
selling each other that we don't like
each other based on what generation when
I grew up I didn't even know I was Gen X
I didn't I never heard pumer I didn't
know right we didn't know about
Generations that meant nothing that was
some [__] maybe you heard in History
Class once now you've got 60 year-olds
fighting
20-year-olds you got 6 you got
50-year-olds judging 20-year olds when
they made them mhm maybe if you didn't
give an eighth place trophy your kid
wouldn't be
entitled like you know like but I I'm so
sick of us hating each other for being
different and we ran out of skin tone
and and and gender and [__] like
religion so now we're on to the next
thing to hate each other about like [__]
this [__] I love gen Z but what does
that mean like there's plenty of gen Z
kids that are working harder than
anybody I've ever seen and are grinders
and there's plenty of gen Z kids that
are lazy good news I know unlimited
people in their 70s cuz I grew up and
watch people who were lazy as [__] as if
every Boomer worked their [__] ass
off unlimited Boomers were lazy as [__]
I saw
them and unlimited gen Z kid I got them
I've got a bunch of these kids on my
team Dustin's 40 but you know like even
though he looks 18 but like I'm being
dead serious he's [__] 39 I cannot
believe
it it's [__] insane yeah it's like my
it's my party trick I bring him
everywhere
wow but like like these kids like I look
at them they're [__] working their
faces off they're not lazy they just
have options jenz is not lazy jenz just
knows the game they can just sell some
[__] on they don't want to work for UK
Kmart for 12 bucks an hour they can just
sell some [__] on eBay or stock they got
options you guys have options
[__] if I had the internet and
social media when I was 15 [__] College
I would have not graduated middle school
middle school on the record I would have
jumped out in fifth grade and be like
peace my mom would have beat my ass I
would have run away and build a [__]
Empire that's what would have [__]
happened these kids got [__] options
[__] they don't want to work in
the Verizon store for nine bucks or 18
bucks they got [__] options they can
go to [__] Goodwill buy nine things
go home make a Tik Tok video about it
put it on eBay and make paper yeah they
got options of course tons of of them
are lazy just like Jen Z it has tons of
lazy so did J X so did Boomers and gen
Alpha that's coming up right now that's
[__] on gen Z these nine-year-olds
got opinions already I don't know if you
know about gen Alpha nah yeah I tell all
my Boomer friends I'm like good news you
don't have to say anything about gen Z
gen Alpha their younger siblings they're
[__] on them for being soft and
[__] soft they these 10-year-olds you
go into these
[__] j z is having a field day right
now [__] on everybody wait to gen
Alpha gets your ass gen Alpha's coming
gen Z and they're going to get your ass
and you're going to be caught like gen Z
is having a field day [__] on
everyone right now again this is all
generalizations but it's going to be
funny when Jen Alpha's biting her ass
and the old get caught in that middle
sandwich let's see what happens anyway
what else do we want to talk about
before we bounce out of here well one
last thing about that I do think there
is a disconnect though between older
generations and younger Generations I
don't know how it is in your family but
like for like it was like respect your
elders oh I love you for this also like
there's so much you can learn from
people who are older than you you know
what I mean but also there is somewhat
of an arrogance too from older not to
generalize but some older people that
are like I know everything of course I
love razing older people too I I'm so
I'm on this kick I think we' put youth
on a pedestal too much and we disrespect
our ERS too much we lost our way it used
to be too far the other way you know we
were coming up the game back in the day
like we didn't get any respect and I was
already knew what the [__] I was doing
like as a businessman but we didn't get
respect like go get the coffee don't do
the real [__] I get it but we've gone
too far the other way we got to find
that middle but yeah there's nothing
more fun than to [__] on an 80-year-old
who's spitting it and I'm like well then
why was your life miserable I had family
members like that trying to tell me how
to live life I'm like nobody likes you
and you're deeply unhappy and you've
achieved no Financial Endor emotional
success the [__] am I listening to you
Auntie I'm being serious I actually had
those conversation I'm being a little
gangster right now but when I was 15 16
and my you know Russian immigrant Elders
tried to give me some game and I was
like I'm not listening to
you you're
sad you like that right like like like
it's real like I always say this I'm
like why are you listening to people
that you don't want to be like yeah for
sure people do that [__] all the time
yeah all right I want to give you guys
the open floor what what do we want to
talk about actually let's go around the
horn and tell people been asking how do
people who are listening live right now
on Twitch and please link it up for them
can they put in links or we don't allow
that in twitch okay okay good please how
can people find you what's your ad
handle which platform um so men's dog on
Instagram spell that out cuz I want
people to Know M NS w a r d o g he's a
dog dressed in men's wear like f like
free endorphins go check it out love it
oh on Instagram it's @ OED padore o b e
d p a d i l l a um who's got the one
without the underscore at the end
somebody else I don't know want you want
me to get that [__] go hit go hit him up
for me bro no no I mean some old like
immigrant [__] like we show at his house
I will go with you all right goe Ken um
Allan King a l a n k i n g did you have
to buy that Alan or you got it from the
G actually very very funny story about
this yeah there's cuz there you're too
young to just have Alan King like that I
know there's something notice I'm I'm
old I know [__] there's no way you just
picked that up when you finally got old
enough that [__] was taken break it down
for me yeah so I I uh DM yeah I dm' this
kid who has alen King and he's like a
he's like I think by way anyone notic
his voice got younger he's remembering
his young see that his voice went
different yeah and uh I was like hey man
like I would really like your username
if it possible you can give me it and
he's like oh no I would like to keep it
I like oh what if I give you like 20
bucks and he's like okay B that's a deal
the best part of this whole you noticed
it right he's like you just went like 16
on us just that's crazy yeah man big
shout out to Tyler Tyler Schmidt who you
guys he has at Tyler oh saw that stop
that is legendary you know what's crazy
when I registered Twitter I signed up
for Twitter four months before I signed
up for Twitter I was in London in
February I think if you look at my
account I believe that I signed up in
May of 200 seven mhm but what's crazy
was this is how crazy the world is I was
in London in February at a Tech
conference it was my first one I ever
went to the first one it was called FAA
future of web apps I'd never been to a
Tech Conference in my life I went to go
check it out and I've never been to
London so I went super cool big shout
out Eric Kastner Eric Kastner my tech
guy at wine library.com went with me
used to film my wine videos when I first
came up we go there and everyone's
buzzing about Twitter this thing is
gonna this is the thing I'm like all
right we went to the hotel room like at
like 10:00 at night after like the
conference and dinner with some people
that we met there and we both went to
register our Twitter handle and somehow
the Wi-Fi in the hotel or something got
[__] up and I wasn't able to register
it and I and I was like okay I'll do it
tomorrow and I didn't and then literally
no [__] it was like 3 months later
that I signed up when it got like when
it became obvious it was going to pop
but what's crazy is when I registered in
May it was the first time in my life
that I ever used the username Gary
ve ever I don't remember what I was
trying to register in February but
what's crazy is that's how I popped off
and that became my brand that's fine
which is just [__] bananas and I
don't remember if I if at Gary was
available cuz it might have been it was
that early Twitter or I was doing just
at Gary V just the first letter but
that's how Gary ve happened on some
technicality on some bad wifi in a
London hotel that didn't allow me to
register Twitter and then I had to do it
3 months later I have no I when I say I
have no idea why I put the two silent e
at the end no clue and like to think
about how that's manifested it's like
future you being like right look be
friends be friends like none of like all
it's just so crazy anyway I love that 20
bucks on a Twitter DM yeah Instagram DM
excuse me I apologize on Instagram DM
all right what uh what's your challenges
right now I I have real passion for
social media content obviously all three
of you have to be thinking about that at
all times which platform in 2024 would
you like to be better at that you're not
popping off on right now for your
business or your
brand um I'd like to be focusing on
YouTube YouTube shorts Tik Tok and
sustaining and keeping Instagram strong
which is more of a challenge now because
organic reach is harder because there's
more Supply
and less consumption yeah absolutely
right I would say YouTube and Tik Tok um
are either one of those strong for you
or not yet Tik Tok a little bit but I
think it's just the consistency and the
amount yep um but that's just something
to just doing it you know yeah right now
I'm really heavy on YouTube as well I'm
trying to build uh I think it'd be
really cool to see a brand being built
like fashion specifically and kind of
have uh the AdSense p for a media person
to help to run the brand and um I I also
want to build LinkedIn up um I I feel
like the LinkedIn on fashion side is is
uh untapped yeah where are you sitting
on live so I'm obsessed right now for
everybody to do more live hence you know
I eat my own dog food I've known about
twitch from the day it was Justin TV I
know Justin like I've watched this
platform explode over the last decade
and I root for it heavy I wasn't into I
wasn't doing gaming I wasn't doing a lot
of live as soon as I knew I wanted to do
this format to do new content to put on
some friends just get some good vibes
but going I knew that I wanted to be
live on Twitch I'm obsessed with Tik
Tock live I think all three of you
should build on Tik Tok live where do
you sit on going live and just chopping
it up like a streamer I think a lot more
people need to use social media lives
the way streamers use twitch yeah like
everybody doesn't go live CU they think
they have to do something I think you
should go live while you're eating lunch
oh that's what I do tell me I do I do
live sometimes on Tik Tok where it's
just me eating and talking to people for
like 2 hours and and as you know and
then my jeans are in the background
because I'm usually in my showroom and
what are you feeling from that how how
often have you done it in the last 90
days real talk don't PLL me two times
slow down a bit do you agree with me
that there's an incredible amount of
Discovery for your brand through that
because what Tik Tok does Instagram when
go live it pings your followers they
come on and then the number goes down
cuz it's hard to maintain the audience
they have other [__] to do Tik Tok you
go live they keep pinging you into
different feeds while you're live so
you're discovering new people you agree
yeah yeah and when your videos are
everybody heard on Twitch if you're
trying to build your [__] cuz I know you
are please pay attention to that yeah
and when your videos are trending then
uh and you go live it also starts
pinging you and showing those videos
yeah so at at certain moments when my
videos are going viral and I was really
trying to grow on Tik Tok I would just
go on live for like two hours 3 hours
that's far mhm Tik Tok live to me right
now is one of the best arbitrages one of
the best ways to day trade attention all
right going around the horn for the end
tell me anything that you wanted to talk
about or you'd like to tell the audience
or build on our conversations as we wrap
up
here um so one thing I wanted to say
today is um SAR and diid there is
0.001% chance that two people born in
the the same time we'll meet each other
and the fact that we're all here today h
is pretty incredible so I just wanted to
acknowledge that I love that U yeah
that's dope I love thaty is that what's
the number you've looked that up
0.00001% that people will meet that two
people will meet if they were born like
in the same era that's [__] cool
right I love that sh and you think about
how you meet people and it's so it's
it's so specific and so so so special so
I just uh thought that probability was
crazy thank you on some immigrant [__]
uh I think it's so cool the amount of
people who are here in this country
whose parents came first um but have are
taking
those lessons and all that stuff and
doing something their own way yeah
that's what I'm about right now I love
that brother honestly to so many of us
are able to to stand on the shoulders of
our parents taking a big risk take some
of those old world values but remix that
[__] with our contemporary world I agree
with that I admire it heavy it's why I
love What's happen you know the best
place that happens Fashion's a place but
the best place that happens in America
is
food like people don't understand like
the pizza is like a real immigrant story
and the hot dog is a real like German
like like you know like the brw like the
there's there's like like people take
for granted Pizza like I think we all
know that you know Sushi and Mexican
food in the last 30 years popped off in
America you go back 30 only 30 years ago
you go back to 1989 and like sushi and
Mexican food wasn't like that in this
country like Taco Bell struggled for a
long time even as a fast food play now
they're like essential for sure
essential Cuisines for every every
single American and I and I remind
people when they talk about that like
it's cool like or whatever their
thoughts on I'm like that's what
happened with the pizza that's what
happened with the hot dog like these
things that are like fries like you this
is a new country most [__] was brought
over and so um food is where I always
look at to see that real impact on that
yeah bringing that old recipe to the new
world tweaking it for sure you
know yeah
um
I I think I I I think about I think
about how everybody is uh on on their
own unique path but it's like we we all
have this destination but it's very uh
kind of it's very interesting how we all
have very similar stories even though we
are have it's is kind of like we've
lived in a a mirror right it's like well
we have this very similar stories um
very similar perspectives or different
perspectives but we also uh have our own
unique end goals or and uh where we want
to be at and uh but we all have grown up
in this one uh Earth and universe is
very interesting to me to think about
yeah you know it's funny I I'll close
with this um and thank you for everybody
who's been watching
um on a very similar note I think we've
become incredibly and uncomfortably
selfish in our journey I think we've
really lost our way with neighbors M I'm
really passionate about this with be
friends there's a reason it's called
friends we have this saying and this is
what you just said which is really a fun
way to rap and what you just said I
believe that strangers become
acquaintances acquaintances become
friends and Friends become family and I
think that is the most interesting
journey of the human in my opinion and I
believe that you know pre I love the
internet I love technology I'm about it
but I'm incredibly aware that people in
the ' 50s knew their neighbors different
cuz you just went outside there's only
so much you could do inside yeah and I
feel like we're on to your point we're
on these Journeys and we have a lot of
similarities and I feel like somewhere
in the last 30 40
years we've lost respecting our elders
and we've lost like caring about our
neighbors when I grew up in the ' 80s in
Jersey all my friends moms were like my
half moms back in the 80s like your your
boy's mom could smack you too real talk
like I'm being dead serious and you
thought like oh I'm sorry kind of mom
like you know like and we just like
could you imagine somebody doing that
today in 2023
lawsuits news outlets but that was like
no like please everybody on the stream
if you're if you grew up in the 70s or
80s or 60s like tell them how it was
like and so like I just feel like you
know love thou neighbor like all that
real like heady like like religious [__]
I think we've lost it and I'm
desperately this is even in the meta
like I'm scarily interested in the three
of you knowing each other just a little
something you don't even like even if it
doesn't pop off right now just seeing
each other in a stream or at the airport
and be like yo even like if you don't
remember cuz it was three years from
today you're like I know oh [__] we were
with Gary like I think we need to fight
for more of that yeah I don't know I
root for people heavy I root for people
heavy and I
think too many are booing
everyone too much Envy too much jealousy
too much confusion that somebody else's
flowers success is coming from you my
friends I promise you Tod wrap this up
nobody's happiness success is taken from
you you're taken from you that that
mindset is what's taking from you we
need to flip it thank you three for
being on thank you for having
[Music]
us